let's go to our next caller from the
3:05 area code caller from 305 what's
going on tell me what's on your mind yes
hello my name is Andrew woods can you
hear me
we can hear you Andrew hey sorry sir the
last time that the call dropped no
problem Mike my question
my question today is about health care
okay I understand the importance of
capitalism with respect to being a
driver for innovation and development
and I really do think that in the
majority of situations this is indeed
the best framework to operate under
however when having a conversation about
health care it seems as though people
think that I disagree on this factor
that liberals disagree on this fact and
I think this is incredibly dishonest I
just I my thing is people always think
we're attacking capitalism or something
but I just normally when I think about
capitalism I think a driver for
innovation and development and I don't
understand how pulling money together
and then just distributing I don't
understand where the relation there is
you're doing so such a basic thing
collecting money and then distributing
it to actual hospitals and health care
providers well let me see if I
understand it's a day today for
understanding the question let me see if
I understand what you're saying
that you feel that as a progressive when
you critique our health care system
others interpret that you are
criticizing capitalism even though
you're just specifically criticizing the
health care system yeah I mean that is a
factor to it and then they feel like
they're it immediately triggered because
you know they're ideologues a lot of the
time and just anything that barely
touches capitalism they just you know
get infuriated by well listen you can
critique the the sub the subjecting of
the healthcare system to the free market
right which is not a criticism of
capitalism at large it's just saying hey
capitalism may work regulated capitalism
may work in some industries but we
shouldn't have the profit motive when it
comes to healthcare so it should be it
should be possible to distinguish that
and I understand what you're saying that
if someone says hey I think we should
have the health care system that
Scandinavia has it's called an attack on
capitalism it's not necessarily an
attack on capitalism it's that not every
capita
doesn't work for everything what might
be a better way to say it yeah no
absolutely but my fundamental problem is
the the fact that I don't understand how
having insurance companies present under
some capitalist framework yeah allows
for them to improve in any capacity the
oh yeah the service they are providing
is so simple it's not like surgery it's
not like developing pharmaceuticals
where capitalism works to incentivize
yeah yeah right in fact I think you've
just come across a really good really
good model you've got this great model
you came up with which is health
insurance it's not brain surgery it's an
attempt to reimburse people as little as
possible who are actually doing the
brain surgery yes I really don't
understand it and and and there seems to
be this huge disconnect where people on
the right are championing no it has to
be a free mark but what are you
championing right what improvement is
possible here
yeah and that bothers me all right point
point heard understand it thanks so much
appreciate the call interesting calls
today people are really riled up I think
because of the holiday or something
because it's it's an unusual series of
calls we'll take a break we'll be back
with more right after this